you took a photo of you and your wife
this was mysterious to me because it
looks like you're peering into a
property a property potentially creepy
photo and you posted this and I didn't
know what was going on here well clearly
you're not a fan of ABC's The Bachelor
because I was driving along the road and
I spotted that house
I screamed aloud and said my god that's
the bachelor house and I screech to a
halt and got out and sure enough it
wasn't shooting at the time but it was
and after I posted so that is the actual
bachelor house
bingo-bango baby no one has ever said
bingo bango baby they say it in hockey
okay no they don't
twine seeking miss all right from the
blue line you really put the mail on
that buddy Wow it's a Canadian pirate
yeah but yeah I posted that and allowing
Gale who's like one of the top producers
the show saw it and said hey come by
anytime you want I came by yeah okay it
is so weird I've never been more
enamored and more starstruck when I meet
a reality TV star right I'm not like I
could meet you any day of the week I
don't care you're nobody to me now he's
he's right but if I were to meet Ari
from The Bachelor hmm um no it was
really fascinating I find that show such
a bizarre social experiment and then
imagine if you will we you and I were
having a date right now and we're try
was imagining that five minutes ago
he's sultry little beasts you terrible
little rat so you I feel weird no yeah
don't worry on 18 okay yeah up with all
three of them okay this is dating 2.8 in
my turn yeah for us to go to the fella
cop well actually that's that's what
happens to the bachelor they have like
two on one since three on ones they have
like multiple people dating and so we're
all trying to create this connection and
there's cameras yeah and there's no way
this is a lot like The Bachelor yes yeah
this is actually a lot like eventually
and it's strange yeah without in any of
the sexuality so so you you got to hang
out on the set of The Bachelor what did
you learn I learned that is it
uncomfortable to be there I would be
uncomfortable to be around all these
people that are true you're all making
these sort of Machiavellian moves to
sleep with each other terrible life
choices
yeah it is an interesting life choice
well I'm trying to like dictate cuz
there were certain things where I was
taken aside and say to talk about this
that's what we want to talk about yeah I
know I can't give you the Goss who's
covered in blood yeah I do think it is
there's a weird situation to try and
fall in love with and I also my sort of
when I view it I think it is a window
open in terms of like how we here in
North America kind of view love right
you go on this you have the civil
relationship and at the most monumental
time you sit down and admit that I think
that sometimes I might be closer to
almost falling in love with you right
and it's like you're you want like a
gong to sound and the heavens to open up
and love and I feel like anywhere else
around the world they're like like your
friend who goes to Italy they're like I
love you I love you yeah it's casual but
right here it's like I baked it in a
cake it's the love yeah don't destroy it
or I'll throw myself off a bridge did
you did you meet any of the contestants
like in you know that you were like
you're fans of I have I met I met if
anyone knows who Dean is I met Dean
yeah all the girls do cuz he boy he can
get it I'll somebody share he's he for I
met Jared who's also fine I met bit
Higgins he's also gone happened to your
jaw for God's sake disappeared long ago
boy okay wow wow I met I met a mom man
I'm wheeling and dealing with these
bachelors trying to you know trying to
maybe say the right things so they might
kiss me on my one-on-one you're freaking
me out
I love that you came on to plug Silicon
Valley but instead you just plugged the
back it doesn't need any help I very
well watch true it's a very well watch -
it doesn't need your help but let's get
the word out The Bachelor is coming out
another network check it out
you